lo que estáis viendo ahora son las
cataratas de iguazú una de las siete
maravillas naturales del mundo
por estas cataratas que en más de 1700
metros cúbicos de agua por segundo
sin embargo en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo las cataratas de
iguazú tienen este
[Música]
en el vídeo de hoy vamos a hablar de la
cara más dura del cambio climático en
estos momentos sudamérica está sufriendo
la sequía más preocupante de los últimos
70 años esta sequía afecta
principalmente a brasil argentina y
paraguay y creedme hablamos de una
crisis que puede tener consecuencias
salvajes sobre todo en argentina
[Música]
habéis oído hablar del río paraná
probablemente muchos sobre todo los
tenéis este vídeo desde europa nunca
hayáis oído hablar de este río pero es
la espina dorsal que une toda la región
no sólo hablamos de agricultura sino
también de energía eléctrica y de
transporte es decir que la sequía de
este río puede tener consecuencias
catastróficas en estos países y diréis
pero de verdad hablamos de una crisis
tan grave pues en este vídeo te lo vamos
a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
argentina es famosa por el tango del
peronismo y la pampa argentina esos
enormes campos de cultivo que son la
espina dorsal de la economía nacional
sin embargo ya conocéis el dicho si algo
puede salir mal en argentina saldrá peor
[Música]
aquí en visual políticos hemos contado
todos los detalles de la debacle
argentina desde el éxodo masivo de
empresas hasta su catastrófica política
contra el coronavirus sin embargo había
algo que todavía funcionaba en este país
la agricultura para que os hagáis una
idea argentina es el tercer productor
mundial de soja y creedme la soja
argentina se vende en todo el planeta no
sólo sirve para hacer leche de soja o
productos dietéticos se trata del
principal alimento para los animales de
granja y tanto argentina como brasil y
paraguay están entre los principales
productores esta soja se cultiva en la
pampa que está regada principalmente por
las aguas del río paraná una vez se
recoge esa soja se transporta en barcos
que también van por el río paraná
[Música]
es decir que en lugar de usar camiones
se utilizan barcazas donde se pueden
transportar toneladas de grano río
arriba y río abajo es decir casi toda la
economía de estos tres países depende en
muy buena medida del transporte fluvial
si veis este vídeo desde españa os va a
sorprender porque en españa no tenemos
costumbre de ver ríos que se utilicen
como hidrovía para transporte fluvial
pero en esta zona os puedo asegurar que
es muy importante sin embargo volvemos
al dicho del principio si algo puede
salir mal en sudamérica saldrá peor
[Música]
y la peor sequía en un siglo golpea
brasil mientras lucha para superar el
kobe y diréis pero de verdad hablamos de
semejante desastre cuáles son las
consecuencias reales de esta sequía que
está pasando en brasil argentina y
paraguay hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a hablar de
la tan política es más los que ya estén
suscritos a la tan política seguramente
conozcáis buena parte de esta historia
porque la estamos contando prácticamente
en tiempo real desde nuestra newsletter
y diréis pero que es la tan política
plata política es la newsletter sobre
geopolítica latinoamericana que hemos
creado junto a la consultora pérez
perspectives por sólo cinco dólares al
mes recibiréis tres análisis políticos
en vuestra bandeja de correo eléctronico
todas las semanas en latam político
descubriréis temas tan importantes como
este mismo que por alguna razón apenas
reciben mucha atención de los medios
tradicionales vamos que si queréis estar
bien informados es decir de verdad bien
informados de lo que ocurre en esta
región del mundo la tam política es
vuestra newsletter encontrareis todos
los detalles en la descripción y ahora
sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
arabia saudita del agua seguro que
muchos habéis oído hablar del problema
de la escasez de agua según muchos el
agua va a ser un recurso cada vez más
escasos sin embargo si hay un continente
que en principio no debería preocuparse
ese es latinoamérica
[Música]
latinoamérica representa sólo el 8 por
ciento de la población mundial pero
acumula el 30 por ciento de las
precipitaciones mundiales para que os
hagáis una idea el índice de referencia
para medir la escasez de agua es el
llamado índice falker marc llamado así
por la señora de alimento pues bien
según este índice sólo tres países de
latinoamérica podrían tener lo que se
llama el estrés hídrico por ejemplo
solamente brasil está bendecida con
entre el 12 y el 16 por ciento de todo
el agua dulce que hay en el mundo de
hecho muchos lo llaman la arabia saudita
del agua
[Música]
y de hecho es en brasil más
concretamente en la región de minas
gerais donde nace el río paraná y si es
muy probable que muchos no lo hayáis
oído mencionar nunca pero se trata del
octavo río más largo del mundo o si
contamos con todos sus afluentes
hablamos de más de cuatro mil 800
kilómetros de río fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
y aquí podéis ver como el río paraná
nace en brasil continúa por paraguay y a
la altura de este país es donde nace el
afluente más importante de este río que
por cierto también es navegable hablamos
del río paraguay y si se llama
exactamente igual que el país después
del río paraná continúa su curso hacia
argentina y termina muriendo cerca de
buenos aires sin embargo por mucho
caudal que tenga este río hasta los años
70 la gente que vivía por esta región
estaba demasiado acostumbrada a la
escasez de agua
[Música]
sin embargo por estos años es cuando se
empezaron las primeras grandes obras de
canalización y así es como nació la
hidrovía paraná paraguay y mis queridos
amigos de visual polític por
sorprendente que os suene este proyecto
es uno de los mayores éxitos políticos
de américa del sur- si por algo se
caracteriza en latinoamérica es porque
seamos honestos los países desconfían
entre ellos apenas comercian entre sí y
tienen muchísimos problemas para
cooperar por ejemplo el mercosur fue un
intento de crear un acuerdo de libre
comercio entre los países latinos pero
como ya hemos comentado mil veces en
este canal apenas ha servido para nada
sin embargo la hidrovía paraná paraguay
es un caso de éxito en toda regla y
diréis pero en qué consiste esta
hidrovía pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la columna vertebral de la pampa ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos donde
está el mérito en utilizar un río para
transportar mercancías a fin de cuentas
el río no lo ha construido a nadie y el
río es lo suficientemente profundo basta
con poner barcos sin navegar verdad pues
no veréis para poder enviar mercancías
por un río necesitamos construir un
montón de infraestructuras de entrada
necesitamos dragar los tramos menos
profundos es decir que tenemos que
limpiar el fondo del río para
asegurarnos que siempre va a tener un
nivel de agua que permita que pase en
barcos grandes además hay que poner
señalizaciones presas etcétera vamos que
la hidrovía paraná paraguay podría dar
por sí misma para un vídeo de
megaproyectos pero no sólo hablamos de
ingeniería el río paraná pasa por tres
países distintos paraguay argentina y
brasil es decir que para hacerlo
navegable es necesario que estos tres
países se pongan de acuerdo y si penséis
que eso es fácil mirad todos los
conflictos que hay entre egipto y
etiopía por las disputas del río
sin embargo en este caso tanto argentina
como paraguay como brasil han sido
capaces atentos de dejar a un lado su
fervor nacionalista y acordar algo que
parece insólito de esta región libertad
de navegación es decir que los armadores
de la hidrovía de paraná tienen que
registrarse pero una vez lo hacen pueden
navegar con relativa libertad por todo
el río es más si alguno de estos tres
países quisiera poner algún impuesto al
transporte fluvial tiene que acordarlo
con los demás y diréis en serio venga ya
de verdad no hay ningún debate sobre la
soberanía del río pues lo cierto es que
si algunos sectores del peronismo más
radical en argentina piden reivindicar
la soberanía del río pero por suerte
estamos hablando de sectores bastante
minoritarios al menos por ahora es más
la mayor parte de las obras de dragados
en el tramo argentino del río los hace
atentos una empresa privada y además no
argentina habéis oído bien desde el año
1993 una empresa belga llamada jan de
nul se encarga de buena parte de las
obras de mantenimiento del río y diréis
en serio nadie ha hecho manifestaciones
para exhalar a las malvadas empresas
extranjeras vendepatrias de argentina
pues de nuevo hay algunos sectores del
peronismo más radical que reclaman echar
a todas las empresas privadas
vendepatrias
pero por el momento esos sectores
minoritarios dicho de otra forma nadie
quiere tocar lo que está funcionando
viviréis pero de verdad funciona tan
bien esta hidrovía pues os voy a dar
unas cifras en este momento el 80 por
ciento de las importaciones y
exportaciones de paraguay van por este
río en el caso de argentina hablamos del
70 por ciento de todo el grano que
exportan que pasa por el río paraná para
que os hagáis una idea en el año 2019 el
puerto de la ciudad de rosario llegó a
exportar 79 millones de toneladas de
grano es decir que según algunos
informes el puerto de rosario es el
mayor nodo portuario agroexportador del
mundo
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de transporte también hablamos
de energía porque a lo largo del río
paraná hay presas por ejemplo la presa
de itaipú y la presa de yacyretá que
generan energía tanto para paraguay como
para brasil y como para argentina dicho
de otra forma que el río paraná es el
nervio que une estos tres países y
diréis y qué ha ocurrido ahora pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y
jugando con fuego si hay una causa
social con glamour en este mundo esa es
la lucha contra la deforestación del
amazonas desde madonna hasta leonardo
dicaprio todos los famosos del mundo han
protestado en algún momento de sus vidas
por la deforestación del amazonas y la
pregunta que os habéis hecho algunas
veces pero de verdad hablamos de un tema
serio o simplemente es un eslogan para
quedar bien de cara a la galería
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que la amazonas es un
tema mucho más serio de lo que parece
veréis según un estudio que os dejo en
la descripción existe una correlación
clara entre la deforestación y la lluvia
basicamente cuantas más hectáreas de
selva se pierden menos lluvia cae por
supuesto que hay muchas comillas que
podríamos poner aquí por ejemplo la
deforestación del amazonas llegó a su
pico en el año 2004 y desde entonces el
ritmo de deforestación ha ido
decreciendo ahora bien esto no significa
que el problema haya desaparecido cada
año se siguen perdiendo miles de
hectáreas de terreno selvático y diréis
pero por qué pues porque mucha gente
quiere quemar grandes áreas de terreno
para poder cultivar habida cuentas la
selva puede ser muy importante para el
medio ambiente pero su rentabilidad
económica es nula dicho de otra forma
que existe un incentivo muy alto para
convertir grandes zonas de selva en
terrenos cultivables y todo esto explica
que el gobierno de brasil tome medidas
como ésta
brasil vuelve a desplegar tropas en la
selva del amazonas para prohibir los
incendios sin embargo por mucho que
brasil envía al ejército el daño ya está
hecho los efectos de la deforestación
del amazonas se llevan notando desde el
año 2014 desde entonces la ciudad de sao
paulo que tiene más de 12 millones de
habitantes ha sufrido cortes de agua
frecuentes sin embargo lo que ha
ocurrido en este año 2021 ha sido algo
único ha sido la madre padre e hijo y
espíritu santo de las sequías atentos
brasil en alerta de sequía en cara el
periodo más seco de los últimos 91 años
y esperad un momento porque esto no es
todo el problema con la escasez de agua
en brasil no se nota únicamente a la
hora de abrir el grifo tampoco es algo
que afecte únicamente a los agricultores
en realidad hablamos de un problema que
afecta a toda la economía veréis al
igual que otros países basan su mix
energético en la energía nuclear o en la
térmica brasil depende de las centrales
hidroeléctricas a día de hoy el 65 por
ciento de la energía de brasil viene de
las presas es cierto que en las últimas
dos décadas este país ha hecho todo lo
posible por diversificar sus fuentes de
energía para que os hagáis una idea en
el año 2001 la hidroeléctrica suponía el
90 por ciento de la energía de brasil
pero por mucho que hayan diversificado
los brasileños siguen siendo muy
dependientes del agua y esto explica que
ahora el precio del kilowatio en brasil
se haya disparado o se ha disparado
hasta el punto de terminar tomando
decisiones como esta brasil apuesta por
el racionamiento voluntario de energía
ante la crisis del agua y diréis pero
qué es esto del racionamiento voluntario
de energía pues muy sencillo el gobierno
ha llegado a las grandes empresas de
brasil y les ha pedido que se reorganiza
en sus horarios si consiguen reducir su
consumo entre 4 y 7 horas al día el
gobierno les da ayudas fiscales por el
momento bolsonaro no quiere aplicar
medidas punitivas la pregunta es hasta
cuándo van a poder mantener estas
medidas por lo cierto es que no lo
sabemos lo que sí sabemos es que brasil
no es el único país afectado por la
sequía ni siquiera es el mayor
damnificado por esta crisis el auténtico
drama llega ahora ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
media río abajo lo decíamos al principio
del vídeo el río paraná nace en la
región brasileña de minas gerais dicho
de otra forma que la sequía de brasil
afecta a todos los países por donde pasa
el río necesario argentina el nivel del
río está ya por debajo del metro cuando
lo normal es que rondará los 3 metros
significa que los barcos han tenido que
reducir su carga para poder seguir
navegando pero no sólo hablamos de
argentina otro de los países afectados
es paraguay para que os hagáis una idea
casi la mitad de las exportaciones de
paraguay van a brasil o van a argentino
y estas exportaciones van por vía
fluvial es decir que van por el río
paraná o van por el río paraguay da
igual si hablamos de un río o del otro
ambos están a punto de secarse y por eso
este país ha tenido que tomar medidas
desesperadas
sancionan ley de emergencia en
navegación de los ríos y autorizan
trabajos de dragado básicamente paraguay
ha tenido que desviar una buena parte de
los fondos reservados para los coronas
rescates para dragar los ríos hablamos
de 21 millones de dólares destinados a
limpiar los fondos de los ríos paraná y
paraguay pero esto no es más que un
parche el problema real persiste y si en
paraguay tiene problemas en argentina no
está mucho mejor
la sequía afecta a 70 millones de
hectáreas de cultivos la famosa pampa
argentina se está secando y la poca soja
que todavía se puede cultivar es casi
imposible de transportar para que os
hagáis una idea los costes de las
exportaciones argentinas se han
disparado en un 300% es decir que
hablamos de un problema tan grave que
argentina paraguay y brasil han llegado
al acuerdo de abrir la presa de itaipú
para poder liberar algo de agua a estos
ríos navegables pero de nuevo seguimos
hablando de parches
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que la sequía de
paraná hace que la crisis del canal de
suez que tantas portadas de periódicos
lleno en su momento sea una auténtica
broma hablamos de uno de los problemas
más preocupantes de este año y puede que
sea el golpe definitivo para
habéis oído bien de todos los países
afectados argentina es el que llevaba la
peor trayectoria antes de el coronavirus
argentina ya estaba sufriendo una crisis
económica devastadora el coronavirus y
la pésima gestión del gobierno ha
provocado éxodos masivos de empresas
pero es que ahora la sequía del paraná
está dando al traste con lo poco que
quedaba en pie en este país así que la
pregunta ahora es para vosotros qué
creéis que puede terminar pasando en
argentina habrá consecuencias políticas
de esta crisis existe alguna forma de
solucionar este problema o sólo queda
esperar a que llueva existe alguna forma
de evitar que se vuelva a producir una
crisis de estas proporciones podéis
dejarme la respuesta en los comentarios
y si queréis seguir estando informados
de esta historia y de muchas otras no
olvidéis suscribiros a latam política
tenéis todos los enlaces en la
descripción y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual politics sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
actualizaciones tus agosto de este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]